[Music]
prime minister Muhammad Shia al-sudani
is the first Iraqi leader to officially
visit Syria since the uprising began
more than a decade ago
but unlike other Arab countries Iraq
maintained relations with the Syrian
leadership despite the regime's violent
Crackdown against peaceful protesters
now there's a new Regional order with
much of the Arab world re-engaging with
President Bashar al-assad
we focused our discussions on how to
exploit some new positive developments
in the Arab world and strengthen Arab
cooperation
there's also a new balance of power in
Iraq that many say will allow the
alliance between the two neighbors to
strengthen now because the pro-iran
forces are back in power in Iraq so we
can see that the Iraqi prime minister is
coming is coming back actually to visit
Damascus and have this sort of
improvement in the relationship between
between the two countries Baghdad and
Damascus along with Shia armed groups
backed by Iran didn't just help Syrian
regime forces regain control of much of
the country from the opposition they
cooperated in the fight against isil
which at one point controlled more than
a third of both countries
Syria must not be left to face dangers
alone as it could have negative
repercussions on Iraq and the entire
region
sudani's statement appears to be a
message that the pro-iran groups among
them Iraqis that are still in Syria are
not going anywhere their presence has
been a concern for Arab states who are
hoping the rappra small with the Syrian
leader will counter Iran's influence the
Syrian Iraqi relations in recent years
have been determined and influenced by
non-state armed groups and Regional
players rather than defined by neither
of the countries themselves therefore it
was um in some way contextual realities
that determine the Iraqi Syrian
relations Iraqi sources have told
al-jazeera the future presence of the
pro-iranian troops was discussed in
Damascus but the Iraqi Leader's visit
seems to reaffirm that recent shifts in
Regional Dynamics won't change the
status quo in Syria